The Blinn-Phong reflection model has been around for more than 30 years. It
used to be hard-coded into older GPUs from the early 2000s. It's easy to
evaluate and somewhat intuitive to control. One technique worth mentioning with
this reflection model is that you can get the specular highlight a different
color than the diffuse components. For example, if the specular component is
given a white color, the object looks more like a shiny plastic. If both the
specular and diffused components are multiplied by the same color the material
looks more metallic. However this classic reflection model is not energy
balanced, you'll notice as I change the shininess, the material looks smoother,
but overall the amount of light reflected becomes greater. If you think about
it, this makes a lot of sense. Here's the Blinn-Phong equation again. You take
N dot H, and take the maximum between that and 0, and raise that to the power
of shininess. The graph of the angle between N and H, versus the specular
intensity, is like this. Clearly the area under the graph for cosine squared is
smaller than for cosine, so the amount of energy coming from the surface will
be less as you increase the shininess. Cosine cubed has even less overall
energy. As the shininess goes up, the area under the curve goes down. Two
changes give a better result, one that's both more plausible and easier to
control. One idea is to attenuate the specular term by the lumbersian fall off.
In other words, just like diffuse, make the specular term drop off as the angle
of the light to the surface becomes less straight. N dot L. The other idea is
to make these narrower curves be higher, giving them roughly the same volume at
3D. This idea is captured in the last term. As shininess increases this last
term also increases, when combined with the Lambertian term this new equation
gives a reasonably-balance result. Here is the original Blinn–Phong equation.
You can see with the shininess of three it's overall much brighter than a
shininess of 100. By energy-balanced I mean that changing the shininess does
not noticeable change the amount of energy reflected from the surface, You can
see the effect by running the demo that follows. By the way, this demo puts all
its shaders inside the JavaScript program itself, if you want to look at an
example of how that's done. Using the Lambertian N dot L term also eliminates a
serious problem with specular falloff. You may have noticed it yourself with
the basic Blinn-Phong model. Here's a view of the model with the low shininess
and the light coming up from behind it. The diffuse term drops off smoothly,
but the specular suddenly drops to zero, giving a pretty bad result. By using
the Lambertian dropoff, the specular term now fades properly.